okay welcome to this video do come and
do gaya from Serbia right yeah I learned
a little bit but sometimes I still
confuse those flex classical Kings
Indian i'm going to play the Petrosian
system or not okay avoiding the direct
e5 playing quick at night a 6 yeah those
lines they are yeah they're interesting
I I don't know them too well which is a
problem but you don't know that too well
looks like he's gained some time I mean
very often you can do those kind of
things this kind of Bishop g5 III back
to see one and black has mostly just
weakened but this is probably not one of
those lines this I have my doubts about
but ok it's ok let's try to be quick
with before and c5 playing g5 before
white even has played f3 is normally not
such a great idea but maybe maybe he can
do it I can do it so he wants to play
what exactly with f3 young maybe I
wonder as age 3 m's maybe just 83 for
the moment g4s opening up the G file but
still rather crude and h 5 i'm taking g5
ok so I'm going to take and yeah i was
thinking c5 here yeah come on let's do
that not overthink Metis iam so be five
or takes on a six I was thinking taking
on a six is also an idea the night is
misplaced but I wait I can also do this
in Bishop a three and it's also quite
good quickly opening up the queenside so
we're going to take it yes i an i guess
i will take it the King site at the
moment is saved so I can play on the
queenside Quincy six and possibly
getting the pawn back
I took it takes a while until you really
get some a substantial threat still
wondering how exactly i'm going to play
I don't like to to do that very much but
then I want the porn back not for the
sake of the poem and I want to get to
the c7 pawn making some progress but
neglecting f2 is a little bit on the
risky side now we yes no square for this
night maybe I should have played Bishop
b5 the month before going to see six
yeah this would have been better a group
c 1 this Bishop evaders a useful time
anyway now that was this would have been
better probably
interesting bishop c6 he wants to play
rogue behavior okay I can do that and
then take on a seven yeah very difficult
to assess this disposition c5 Bishop c5
might be on yeah I really don't know but
I don't want to fall any further behind
on the clock jay-z form attending Bishop
c5 at one moment but it's okay i can
probably play Bishop b5 a move like that
Oh interesting allowing this is
interesting looking at all the critical
square c4 c6 and so on it may be queen
is 6 out if they're the moment is right
I can do that my king is saved as thats
it's really really important but what am
i doing now Queen to be five or maybe
just a for a fire I can probably just
push the airport here he has no counter
play Queen age 7 but I have Quincy form
and my king is safe as mentioned
idea is Queen see for a six just just
simple simple chess yeah it looks good
it looks good everything's nicely
covered and protected it's very little
counter play I guess you should maybe
try some my queen to be a door something
can always go queen be five though yeah
okay but it's not a thread there's no
real threat involved here h 5 h 4 and so
on but that's really slow can go all the
way back then push the porn queen h 0 is
also a good good move coming that will
support the a prime morning i can go
here yeah queen bee eight Queen B 5
or queen a to be a Q&A to is also strong
so a seven I am Bishop to c5 but there's
still wait let's think for a moment ni
p5 is good
I'm intending night to d2
and I should move just kind of falling
asleep here in the position where
probably many moves with a winner Jack
Wow no he took you they took their know
wow what kind of nonsense is dead oops
why Jack what kind of game was that ah I
just totally fell asleep here in this in
this in this in this position I didn't
what what happening here yeah I'm eight
seconds add on the clock and have a
totally winning position and then i got
totally irritated that was stupid I mean
I mean everything winds him check even
that which is kind of kind of idiotic
yeah i can just promote him you can give
a double check check this is really just
one check it now ed had removed this
because i thought if summer woods would
promote and he took there yeah which is
of course hmm and resins and i had pre
moved pre-move night see one after which
i'm losing come on aim yeah no I mean
how can you lose it this game it was
like a complete one-way street white was
winning like from here almost
check hmm yeah I need to break ah thanks
for watching anyway